because the conspiracy theory is that
there's this giant international child
sex trafficking Network going on that is
being covered up that's what's going on
and if you look at Jimmy Tsavo in the UK
that brought a lot of light right is
that a saddle saddle yeah that was a
terrifying yeah so with the story with
him is Jimmy Savile he's dead now he
died in his 80s in 2011 he was a
super-famous like Dick Clark kind of guy
he was a he was the host of pop Top of
the Pops it's like if your band got on
that show you're gonna be mega he was
huge he was friends with the royal
family with the prime ministers Margaret
Thatcher Tony Blair he looks disgusting
pull up Jimmy Savile does he looks like
a charm look at this guy check this out
but he was 2012
super super famous and you know what he
would do he would raise money for
hospitals and specifically psychiatric
hospitals and he would bring the Queen
of England and he had all this power to
raise millions for these hospitals these
mental institutions he that's what he
prayed for kids so he would what he
would do is he would he would do so much
for these hospitals that he would put
himself on the board and give himself a
job they're in a position and he would
hang out at these hospitals there's all
there's at least five there's at least
five hundred people that have come
forward to say they've been raped by him
when there were a five hundred people at
least he worked you know he worked for
the BBC super famous super he would he
had Christmas dinner with Margaret
Thatcher multiple times what is that red
hat he's got that looks like a maggot
hat right above that yeah there's a
crazy guy who it turns out he was a
child rapist yeah and that's the same
thing with Sandusky and they're covering
it up the quest
oh dude this yes because people knew
they're complicit and they did venture
the mystery the mystery is how is he so
tight with the prime minister's the
royal family all these politicians all
this [ __ ] comes out when he died because
every time there would be an allegation
while he was alive he would just sit
them down and go what are you gonna do
I'm gonna ruin your life
you better drop this [ __ ] what are you
gonna do you think they're gonna come
after me
you know many millions are given this
hospital so he would just shut
everything down and there was all these
underground covered up allegations mitad
getting knighthood was a relief because
it got me off the hook what does that
mean he was knighted right so got him
right the hook what is that he got
knighted when you get knighted could
they could they not arrest you anymore
is that what happens is it like being a
president yeah there's a there's a
documentary on YouTube called the ninth
circle Jimmy Savile the ninth circle you
find out why they covered it up why did
they cover it up widen this aging DJed
is it's like Dick Clark they should have
just mashed him up why was it all being
covered up it's [ __ ] insane when you
find out why how does he answer for dead
bodies in general the chief owner of
dead people why he loved [ __ ] dead
people where'd you hear this it's you
then it's a nice memory the ninth circle
Jesus Carlin sees watch that Jesus
Christ it's insane it's insane when you
find out when you watch that [ __ ] dude
it is crazy that you like you're saying
this and it sounds like like they could
never impossible it sounds like it never
could be possible that some giant
television star that worked with
children it was always helping our
children could have actually been
[ __ ] them the whole time and a bunch
of him hundreds of raping him and then
people must have known there's no way
everybody he was killing he was killing
them he was killing moved think I found
all these bodies it's a box it's a big
scandal in the UK dude Jesus Christ
there's an island called Jersey Island
that's owned by the Queen and look into
that [ __ ]
I don't even want that I don't want to
get that deep into it because I have a
rape children as young as nine while
working at BBC leaked report unveils and
this is in the independent yeah how come
we're not how come there's not the same
kind of effort for this kind of stuff
like there is what the the gun shooting
the Florida school shooting why isn't
there that that's not a big event where
it's one thing where all the deaths
happen and what deaths or deaths I
understand I'm with you I understand but
I mean this is also why people don't
freak out about five hundred thousand
people dying every year because of
obesity like what would you what's worst
what's worse having your kid get shot at
a school shooting or having that
[ __ ] rape your daughter and
multiple times and then kill I don't
think what's worse exactly
yeah it's just what's scary is that that
is being protected yes there's someone
that either knew about it and now is
trying to cover their ass because they
knew about it that was that's the thing
about Sandusky you know San Gus ki did
the same thing he was raping all these
kids and the whole time he was running
these programs for underprivileged
children and helping all these orphan
kids you gotta watch her kids man
you got a lot actually got away with
abusing five hundred children and sex
with dead bodies whoa
hanging out with the Queen dude this
guy's tight with the look at him to God
and all these little kids around them
you know I want to tell you why he got
why they left him alone you do know
according to the ninth circle what is
the night so it said it's a documentary
about the whole thing won't cover on cuz
everybody's doing it they're all doing
it he was supplying everybody with kids
that's what he used the hospitals for
well this is not a new theory this is
not a new theory when it comes to like
groups of freaks
he was the pimp yeah he was supplying
everybody with kids this is this is
something that people have talked about
like very intelligent people that I know
that have talked about in terms of like
there's been stories about people that
have taken politicians to like islands
and [ __ ] because that's where they keep
like young girls you know I don't know
why I'm looking
dude and you know what but you know but
this but someone talked to me about this
and they were saying you have to
understand that if you are in a group of
incredibly wealthy people and you have
extreme desire for extreme sexual
scenarios whips and by and you can't
whatever the [ __ ] it is you can't young
girls you can't let anybody know about
this so people come into these people's
lives that can facilitate these things
and then they develop a sort of bond of
silence and this is how when this [ __ ]
gets out of hand you can get a jimmy
savile or you can get a Jerry Sandusky
that's the other thing about Sandusky
there was like this is not sky was not
on his own like he was supplying iceberg
what wasn't that one of the things that
doesn't come up
Sandusky Google Sandusky was supplying
children to other pedophiles because
that was something that was also
speculated about some of the donors that
were donors to his his charities were
also somehow involved in molesting those
kids you know what a death ride is death
ride death ride no jimmy savile what
would supply 10-15 boys to a certain
politician he'd have a boat you take him
out on the boat he could he couldn't
afford to have any witnesses so those
were always the last rides those kids
would take they're called death rides
ninth Circle C but how do they know that
for a fact that is you just gotta watch
it and and make the conclusion yeah I'm
not I'm not ruling he's already a [ __ ]
back so you got a look at him like a
prosecuting attorney not a defense
lawyer he's already a [ __ ] he's
already confirms already ripping kids
what's the stop and telling exactly
exactly yeah I mean that's a good point
because if you're the type of person
that could rape a child what can't you
do yeah and that's what I'm saying right
in in the UK the numbers could be wrong
but I heard that every three seconds a
child is reported missing in the UK ever
that's 175 thousand kids a year get
reported missing in the in just the UK
it's a big business man there's got to
be more than that
it's a jackings in a years know
every three seconds at 175,000 that
seems low every 30 minutes I'm so oh
everything not everything seconds I'm
sorry I'm sorry every three minutes
every three minutes this is according to
something I saw 31 million seconds in
the day yeah yeah I'm sure the numbers
are probably 100 175 thousand isn't as
big as 800,000 a year but damn